who would you not want to see walk
through the doors of celebrity big
brother house
oh gosh who would i not want to see a
big brother um
hmm
i'm pretty open and amenable to
absolutely everybody and i think um
but um
mean people would be terrible i'm trying
to think who's me
um like maybe like a really mean pro
wrestler that would be scary
or um
um
i don't know i'm gonna have to think
about who's mean
all right
um
so you talked about this earlier as a
celebrity you know you're accustomed to
people watching your every move and uh
seeing that you know and living under a
bit of a microscope are you ready for
the public to see you in a different
light watching you 24 7.
okay so the thing is i've done about
so the thing is i've done about 5 000
reality shows i made
kind of a reality tv tween if you will
um but they're still pretty controlled
like i get to you know like make sure
like i have some powder on and i'm not
shiny and my hair is done
um this doesn't just happen so rolling
out of bed with cameras on 24 hours it's
gonna be it's gonna be a little scary
canada
buckle up
and expanding on that so what part of
yourself are you the most scared or
embarrassed for the public to see hmm
so i am you know i
love to dress well it's kind of my jam i
love style i love fashion um people do
not need to see me getting out of the
shower okay let's just say things are
dragging on the ground at this point i'm
old
okay and why do you feel right now is
the right time in your career to take
this leap of faith and join the
celebrity big brother world
so why is the timing right now in my
career do this you know what i this is
what i do i do television i do reality
tv so why not